[Music]
is ever so subtle gets this
here
straight
[Music]
he doesn't read across he's not stepping
through but okay you got it
I'd say you would you there's some point
right you gonna shuffle it boom hey so
my hands are here I'm gonna get the
corner and you'll see it
don't look for your classic
[Music]
so this hands I think about them
it's just weaving
what's happening I'm getting sick so he
goes right and he's sitting here so I'm
taking my guard and I'm moving it so my
guard moves and does the slight position
and leaves so I know I'm not going like
this see that my guard is here I move
out of the way I feel it and I lift up
elbow up and same side though my guard
is chair
boom I move see how we're stuck you skip
defy not as I let it go boom okay you're
not blocking he's running the
engineering are free it up and come
around you're to talk you're you're too
far see how your punches going up on me
so if I go like this I'm not gonna get
so I can't do it all here no thanks Oh
boom that little tiny bit
I'm just showing you the kiss issue
right requested that and then boom comes
the strike okay
[Music]
you gonna go on that 45 and then is all
you got gold and it starts coming in
check check oh do you guys understand
okay so you're here and you you strike
right right here's my face so I can't go
like this
the fight isn't gonna stay here they're
gonna just turn it strike again but so
what you're doing is a boom you're
hitting right here do you guys see that
so we go slow eater slow I'm here
I changed angle and that's all I get
she's gonna try to turn you see it and
I'm moving inside the turn so full full
everything is there so I can't pull this
out all right thank you here to make
contact and then that's fixated movement
okay I'm going to take the same thing
and make it for closer that's my
technique okay so one right here like
this I'm not going like this
face it I'm here boom boom and boom on
the inside of my heart you see that
angle you can think of it as I'm here
boom I hit right I'm here booming I hit
well I hope you hear oh man I hit we got
it with this energy okay